في تركيا توصل الاحزاب المعارضه توجيها
الانتقادات لسياسه الحكومه في التعاطي مع
الزلزال لتؤكد بان حجم الكارثه اظهر عجزا
في التعاطي معها فعواقب الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب عده مدن تركيه ستستمر طويلا
وستكون النقطه الابرز على حملات
الانتخابات التشريعيه والرئاسيه التي
ستعقد خلال اشهر وتاخذها حكومه اردوغان
على انها التحدي الاكبر للتخفيف من
تداعيات الزلزال المدمر
وفق تقرير نشرته وكاله بلومبرغ قال احد
زعماء المعارضه ان تراكم السلطه السياسيه
بيد اردوغان وضعف الاستجابه السريعه اعاق
جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
وباتت السلطات اقل كفاءه من جديد غير ان
الحكومه ردت ووصف التصريحات الاحزاب
المعارضه بغير اللائقه داعيه في الوقت
نفسه لتضافر كافه الجهود مع تزايد حده
التململ والاستياء في وسط المواطنين مشيره
ان اردوغان اقر ببطء الاستجابه للزلزال
وان تحقيقا سيفتح لمعرفه الاسباب
الزلزال الذي ادى لانهيار الاف البنايات
وتسبب في مقتل العشرات وتشريد الملايين
يمكن ان يكون ورقه مهمه في الانتخابات
وماده للتنفس بين اردوغان واحزاب المعارضه
جو مشحون بالتوترات السياسيه وحتى
الاقتصاديه تنظر بانتخابات صعبه على
الطرفين خصوصا الى توافقت المعارضه ونجحت
بتقديم مرشح مشترك لمنافسه اردوغان